ja die oberste regel sie ist vor allem
autofahrern bekannt bis o also oktober
bis ostern da sollen autofahrer
winterreifen aufziehen und diese regel
will sich nun gesundheitsminister
lauterbach als vorbild nehmen und zwar
für corona beschränkungen das heißt dann
ganz konkret eine generelle masten
pflicht von oktober bis ostern
das berichtet zumindest die welt am
sonntag und darüber müssen natürlich
reden mit bild parlaments chef ralf
schuler reif was ist denn jetzt davon zu
halten o bis o regel für die masken
fläche ja mal eine tolle neue regel wir
hatten bisher die frischluft riegel und
allen anderen sachen der
gesundheitsminister ist mal wieder in
panik modus und im regelungs furor das
ist schon langsam wirklich ärgerlich wir
wissen noch nicht was im oktober sein
wird aber beschließen schon meine masken
pflicht politik muss auflagen reagieren
aber sie muss nicht irgendwelche
sinnlosen beschlüsse im vorfeld treffen
das ist schon ziemlich irre was er da
macht und das ärgerliche daran ist er
hat jede menge andere baustellen die wir
bespielen müsste es gibt einen riesen
loch bei den krankenkassen müssen unsere
beiträge steigen oder wird
steuerfinanziert nein er plant für den
winter etwas obwohl er nicht weiß welche
lage dort ist das schon sehr ärgern was
glaubst du was hat er noch für pläne in
petto wird ja auch gleich eine
pressekonferenz abhalten die wir hier
auch live übertragen werden was kann da
noch kommen ja karl lauterbach plan seit
langem verschiedene vorsorge regeln also
beispielsweise war ja auch ein großer
fan der impfpflicht und möchte ganz
gerne das infektionsschutzgesetz so
anpassen dass man jederzeit dann wieder
neue einschränkungen beschließen kann
lockdown sind in der ampel er nicht mehr
wohlgelitten aber man weiß nicht genau
wie diese formulierung aussehen es ist
schon einfach irgendwie bizarr dass man
vor dem sommer mit solchen regeln kommt
die man jederzeit wenn eine lage da ist
nach führen könnte vor allem weil auch
virologen sagen das wäre gar nicht so
schlecht wenn man sich tatsächlich jetzt
im sommer leicht infizieren würde dann
hätte man einen besseren schutz für den
herbst hat sie absolut wir haben im
augenblick nach allen wissenschaftlichen
erhebungen eine immunitätsregelung von
etwa 95 prozent das ist besser als je
vorher wenn dort eine neue variante um
die ecke kommt dann nützt einem das
sowieso wieder nichts aber
warum dinge beschließen nur um aktionen
zu machen das ist schon sehr seltsam und
mehr verbreitet panik das ist nicht die
aufgabe eines gesundheitsministers das
ist es vor allem die menschen werden
jetzt hellhörig und haben auch wieder
teilweise angst besten dank reichlich
habe den eindruck als ob man carlotta
aber auch immer weniger zuhört hier
öfter er sowas verkündet mal sehen was
dann nachher zu sagen hat dank